[موسيقى]
كان الرفيق بسام اول الامر ثم صار بشار
ابو سمره قبل ان يجد ورقه نعي على عمود
الكهرباء تحمل الاسم ذاته فالغى استخدامه
وظل على الدوام فواز طرابلسي الطفل الذي
ولد عام 41 لاسره قادمه من دمشق وقد سماه
ابوه تيمنا باسم صديقه احد امراء قبيله
الروضه في باديه الشام عاش فواز طول حياته
مناضل اشتراكيا من اجل تحرر الوطني
كان الحدث المؤسس بواعيه الوطنيه العدوان
الثلاثي تشكلت الهزيمه تحولا من الالتزامه
القومي تجاه الناصريه والبعث الى انقلاب
جذري في فكره حياته فان سحب بعد اقامه
سريعه في حزب الباحث العربي الاشتراكيه
وقاده واسس تنظيمين ماركسين هما لبنان
الاشتراكي ومنظمه العمل الشيوعي شارك في
الحرب الاهليه في لبنان واسامه في اطلاق
جبهه المقاومه الوطنيه اللبنانيه ورافق عن
كثب تجارب تحرريه عربيه كثيره منها حركه
التحرر الفلسطيني ثوره ضفار حركه التحرر
الوطني للبحرين والخليج سافر الى باريس
لاستكمال الدراسه بعد توقف عندما اوام
للتفرغ للعمل الحزبي نال بعد هالدكتوره
وعاد الى لبنان ليباشر التعليم في الجامعه
اللبنانيه الامريكيه ثم في الجامعه
الامريكيه في بيروت كتب في الاقتصاد
والانثروبولوجيا والتاريخ والنقد الادبي
والفني وفي الثقافه الشعبيه والفلكلور
وكان مراده كما يسميه دائما تصنيع التجار
حيث يؤمن طرابلس بان اضعف تعبير عن
العلاقات الاجتماعيه والسلطه والتعبير
السياسيه من كتبه تاريخ لبنان الحديث من
الاماره الى اتفاق الطائف تتبع فيه
المراحل التاريخيه الاهم في تاريخ ومسيره
لبنان من اماره جبل لبنان في العهد
العثماني اصولا الى اتفاق الطائف وكتاب
حرير وحديد من جبل لبنان الى قناه السويس
كتاب سوره الفتى بالاحمر وهي مذكراته التي
يحكي فيها عن نشاته بعضه وعمله نظالي في
الستينيات والسبعينيات وكتاب ظفار شهاده
زمن الثوره وغيرها من الكتب يعد الرجل من
اكثر واهم مؤرخ على فكره اليسار في العالم
العربي وكتب عناه ومساراته وتجلياته
مشاهدينا الكرام الدكتور فواز طرابلسي ضيف
هذه الحلقه من المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اريد ان اعود للبدايه يا دكتور فواز
والنشره نشات اعرف انه كان الوالد يعمل في
سوريا فتره ثم عاد وسمعنا شيء منها من هذه
القصه عمل ايضا في مجال الدباغه ثم في
فندق خاص للعائله وما الى ذلك في يعني في
اسيرتين الحقيقه انا مربوط مرتبط وبالتالي
يعني هو مسؤول كثير بان حبابني باللغه
حببني بالتاريخ وفي الشقه الثانيه تمام
مختلف وهو يعني
[موسيقى]
وهي من جنوب البقاع
بلده اسمها مشترى وهي اسره
[موسيقى]
من الدباغه الى العمل الفندق
يعني تمام
[موسيقى]
عيش بفندق وهو كان بيديك الفتره الفندق
يتلقى يعني
البلدان العربيه
مصري عراقي
[موسيقى]
وتر السعوديه
وبالتالي يعني كان اسم الفنانين يعني هذا
الفندق
محمد عبد الوهاب عبد الغني السيد
فابتلي يعني مناخي ليس بعيدا عن اللغه
العربيه اصلا وكذلك درست بمدرسه اسمها
مدرسه الرمانه العالي وهي مدرسيه
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي كانت مدرسه داخلي سمحت يعني كثير
اني يعني اقرا عربي نقرا انجليزي
ما احضر دروس الفرنسيه
فكانت مناسبه تلقين خلال سنوات
الطلاب ضد الاداره وهي اداره بريطانيه بس
الاهم الحدث الاساسي كان 56
مدرسه انجليزيه وعدوان السويس له كان
تاثير يعني على المنطقه
وبالتالي بدرج عنا تقليد التظاهرات يعني
كنا نقفل المدرسه
نضرب احتجاجا على عدم ااا مثلا الاحتفال
15 ايار
هو الاثر الثاني كان الثوره الجزائريه
الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
من باب الصراع الطبقي جيت من باب قومي من
زاويه قوميه ثقافيه شو اللي حببك شو اللي
خلاك تسير في هذا يعني خلينا نقول فيه
بدايه
اكتشاف انه عند استلام اليسار للحكم تبين
يعني
برامج الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وبالتالي
يعني كان جدي بالنسبه لنا يعني ربط عبد
الناصر والبعث بين الوحده والحريه
والاشتراكيه فكان وكنا بيعلم همم
وكلنا بحركات تحرك يعني تدعو الى القوميه
والى الاشتراكيه
كثير غريب ان يلتزم يعني شخص قومي اذا بدك
ويعتبر حاله الى اليسار
بالاشتراكيه ومنها طبعا اكتشاف انه التراث
الزاخر
في الاشتراك على تنوع
من باب الصراع الطبقي من باب معاناه طبقيه
انتمي متوسطه
[موسيقى]
وكان صديق يحب مؤسسه الحزب وهو ابن بلده
بس مش اكثر من هيك يعني ما كان حسبي
رقص دخولك اليسار والعالم الاشتراكيه ليس
مساله وراثيه يعني لم يترك لم يترك اثرا
مناخ مقصوم بين قومين الشيوعيين وكان لي
ابن عمه كانوا تاثير عليه احد قاضيه حزب
الشيوعي
بالبلديين العرب المدرسه
[موسيقى]
واا بالباب الحاره
50 60 طالب يعني متمردين على
يعني الاداره لانه الاداره قاومين سوريين
وانجليزي
وفي المدرسه كان الحزب القومي السوري
الاجتماعي هو التيار السائد
العربي
المتاثر
عبد الناصر الابيض
وجهه الى بريطانيا 58
لدراسه الجامعه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
يعني ما كمل دراس يعني
وقتها بدها نشاطي بحزب البعث
الدراسه
طبعا في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
غير بعيد
يعني مباريات فوتبول مهتمين يعني في ايه
وشاهدت شيء سميته الفقر الصناعي اللي يعني
لا شاب عمره 18 سنه كان فيه شويه مختلف
ايضا افكارك الاوليه والاساسيه في موضوع
في نشاطات الاسره وايضا مارست السياسه
بشكل
الرئيسي يعني ثلاث سنوات في حزب البعد رغم
يعني
65 بس خلال يعني
مؤيدين الانفصال عبد الناصر
[موسيقى]
قال انه فواز طرابلسي اهم من الرخا لتاريخ
الافكار بشكل عام واليساربي بشكل خاص
بالعلم العربي العربي
[موسيقى]
63 قاد البعث انقلابا في كل من العراق
وسوريا وبين ما استولى الحزب صاحب الشعرات
القوميه على الحكم في بغداد في شهر فبراير
قبض على مقاليد السلطه في دمشق في شهر
مارس الذي يليه
ورغم ان الدولتين حكماهم الحزب نفسه لعقود
طويله الا ان العلاقات بينهما لم تمضي نحو
الاتحاد بالسلكت مسار القطيعه والصراع
بدات بذور الخلاف بين جناحي البعث عقبه
تسل محافظ الاسد السلطه عام 70 حين اتخذ
التنافس المحموم رابعا ايدولوجيا قبل ان
يتطور الى نزاع على الزعامه القوميه
والحزبيه
وفي اكتوبر عام 73 شارك الجيش العراقي
بالحرب الى جانب الجيشين المصري والسوري
غير ان بغداد اتهمت دمشق بالعمل على
استبعادها من المعركه
توقيعي مصر اتفاقيه كامب ديفيد جرت
محاولته تقارب بين سوريا والعراق من بوابه
تبني ميثاق العمل القومي المشترك تمهيدا
لانهاء القطيعه واقامه وحده عسكريه تكون
مقدمه لوحده سياسيه بين ان هذا الاتفاق
لفظ انفاسه في يونيو عام 79 مع انتقال
السلطه في العراق الى صدام حسين الذي
ادعكتشاف محاوله انقلابيه يديرها بعثيونه
بدعم مباشر من سوريا
بلغ التوتر بين الجانبين ذروته بعد مشاركه
القوات السوريه في اخراج الجيش العراقي من
الكويت في اطار مع عرف بحرب الخليج
الثانيه
توقفنا عند الانضمام لحزب البعث الانضمام
لم يكن 61 بعد عودته بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
وكان في يعني طلاب شويه
فا هذا الجو الطلب العربي فيك تتصور انه
نحن عم نحكي عن عمتي 58 موضوع فلسطيني
[موسيقى]
انجورون بتذكر في بلده اسمه وردتون
يعني هذا النشاط الرئيسي اضافه الى النشاط
التضامني اااه مع فلسطين وطبعا كلنا
نستدعى الى
لندن عند مجيء مسؤولين يعني من زمان وقتها
كان في جراه
[موسيقى]
وقت
ايه ناقص من اكبر من الوقت
الى لبنان للعمل بشكل اكبر الحياه كان
يعني طموح جامعي بس الاهل يعني اثره ارجاع
والولد كان دائما عنده استعداد انه يشتغل
يعني بالاخير
يعني كان اعتبار انه بدانا يعني حياتنا
المهم متعوده الى البلد اللي ممارسه
وصلت 65
لا وصلت وصلت دخلت بحزب البعث
عند وصوله جمدت بحزب البعث لانه كنت على
الصلاه مع مجموعه اكرم الحوراني اللي كانت
ماسكه القياده في لبنان ولم اعد الا بعد
ما استلم حكم البعث بالعراق وسوريا
وبعديك بتلك الفتره يعني كنا مجموعتين
الحيه مجموعه بحي النبعه وهو حي شعبي
بضاحيه بيروت الشرقيه
ومجموعه الجامعه
البعث الحكم بالعراق
همم كنا ضد اضطهاد الشيعيين ضد الحرب
والسلام يعني بيشكر اصدرنا وثيقه
وفصلت بناء عليه
سرعات كانت كثيره جدا في تلك الفتره ما
بين الاحزاب حتى بالخلفيه اليسريه
والاشتراكيه يعني وكانها يعني لم لم توجد
تسويه
وعقد ناظم لكل هذه المجموعات كانت
انشقاقات دائما من كل حزب الى احسن حزب
اخر او من كل فرع الى فرع اخر
السنه بس لا يمنع بانه كانت فتره من
النقاشات الفكريه والسجلات المحفزه على
التفكير والتحصيل طبعا في كل الانشقاقات
المدره كمان بس يعني لا تشبه الان يعني
كان الحماس
للتفكير وللسجاد والكتابه همم اكبر بكثير
بالبعث هالمجموعتين لذكرت لك اياهن يعني
سهام وبتاسيس مجموعه اسمها لبنان
الاشتراكي
وهي يعني مجموعه محدوده كانت انما يعني
انتاج
الاساسي كان يعني مجموعه مفاهيم تتعلق
بلبنان يعني نحن الي اشتغلنا شوي على
خصوصيات الاقتصاد اللبناني
اشتغلنا على فكره
القطاع السياسي وهو موجود يعني فئه سياسيه
ليست هي السلطه الاقتصاديه انما تخدمها
وعن الظاهره الشهابيه اللي كانت يعني يمكن
ابره الظاهره بتاريخ لبنان وهو يعني
اجى بعد 58
وكان شعاره
يعني بناء دوله الاستقلال
واجره عدد واسع من الاصلاحات من التنميه
الريفيه الى
القضاء على الاجتماعيه يعني هو مؤسس
الضمان الاجتماعي في لبنان مؤسس العقود
الاجتماعيه
غير منتمي للمركز
وبالتالي الى اي ماده طبعا في حيف اجتماعي
في بؤره صغيره اسمها بيروت وجبل لبنان
تستغفر بكثير من الثروه والخدمات الدوله
فمثلا التجربه
يعني الجيش والامن
التكنوخرات انما شكل بتاريخ لبنان مح
متماسك همم لاجراء احصاء اصلاحات بكافه
المجلات وهو استدعى يعني
همم مركز دراسات شهير اسمه ارفد كشف
للبنانيين انه في فقر في في تمركز الثروه
لي ولا مره كان يعني كان البلد عائش بهناء
انه معجزه اقتصادي
كمان وكبنا هالظاهره همم
ثم جاءت يعني
هذه المرحله اللي كانت مرحله نظارات شعبيه
عامه يعني لبنان 64 لا ال 74
الان يرى بصفته يعني مقدمات حرب شو كان
ايضا يعني مقدمه عالم من يعني
انتفاضات كل فئه شباب لبنان يعني تبدا من
الطلاب ولا تنتهي بالفلاحين وباتحاد نقابه
جدا قوي
ومتماسك طبعا على هذه هبطه 67
لكن ايضا في في مسار المنظمات الاشتراكيه
كان في اكثر من مجموعه اندمجت مؤخرا يعني
نهايتنا ندمجت انت ووضح شراره وبيضون في
منظمه العمل الشيوعي ايه هو يعني هي
المظله الجامعه بعد 67 مثل ما هو معروف
يعني حدث هيك علاقه طريفه بين احزاب
الشيوعيه مالت اكثر نحو المسائل القومي
يعني حركات قوميه مركز التعبير
الكبرى
والانشقاقات الكبرى
بداخل حركه العرب يعني من اليمن الشمالي
للخليج
وصولا الى فلسطين ولبنان
بلبنان يعني نشا همم
معظم فرع الحركي كان الى جانب يعني محسن
ابراهيم محمد
اليسار
بالحركه كله
مجموعه لبنان الاشتراك الصغيره
العرب وقد تحول الى منظمه الاشتراكين
لبناني
[موسيقى]
اصبحت لاحقا النائب العام
انا كنت يعني
انا عشت 67 في لبنان
تخرجت من الجامعه الامريكيه قبلت
يعني
كليه الدراسات الشرقيه
والافريقيه الاسيويه الافريقيه بجامعه
لندن
يعني كنت بقول اني اعمل دكتور دكتور
رحت على الفرصه يعني انا 68 71 زياره
القادم التاليه
نفس الشيء نشاط فلسطين
فلسطين
بريطانيا ثم بفرنسا محل ما رحت له وصل
يعني ابحاث مش دراستي
وبالتالي كمان تجربه كمان مختلفه يعني اي
مفتوح
امام المستقبل
هذه التجربه يعني
لها مراقب اسكان انه الاستاذ المشرف على
طول رحت مكان في اتفاق معه كان يعني
يوناني
تاريخ لبنان
يعني ما هذا السبب الرئيسي بس بسبب
الرئيسي الى لبنان هو انه تم الانتاج
لبنان
السياسيه
عملا في منظمه العمل
اذا بدك
اكثر حبيبي
همم الدكتور انت كاتب ومؤرخ مثقف واكاديمي
صحفي ايضا الحزبي الشخص الحزبي او العمل
الحزبي ماذا ماذا تركه من اثر عليك
كيف تنظر لهذا الدور الذي مارسته في حياتك
في فتره هامه جدا من تاريخ الامه العربيه
انا مؤمن بالعمل الحزمه
ما تغير شيء ممكن الاحزاب لازم احزاب منه
اخر انما ان تجربه
الفعليه تجربه حزبيه همم يمكن يعني عند
مراجعه تجربتي بيقول انه لم اكن عبقريا
يعني انه في ما كثير يعني
الدور القيادي انا مناسب له قرارات بطيئه
تامل
وان يكن يعني تحملت مسؤوليات ومارست
سلبيات قد ما بتاكل عمل القياده انما
خلال الفتره يعني كنت صحفي بنفس الوقت
مجله الحريه بس اقصد المثقف قد يكون عصي
عليه ان يعمل في اطار الحزبيه بعض الاحيان
والله
عليها كثير الى اي مدى الاطار الحزبي يسمح
بتعدد الاراء هو هذا هو الموضوع وهذا مش
خاص بالمسؤوليه يعني في فكره كانه
المثقفين يعني ما بيقبلوا بالاوامريه سائر
البشر ما بقبلوا امريكا
ما عاد يقبلوا اشكال من الاحزاب
بالاوامريه
[موسيقى]
علما بانه يعني الوجه الاخر طريف كمان
واحيانا
المثقفين ببالغوا من حيث عقده الذنب
الولاء الحزبي والانضباط الحزبي
للتعويض عن انه المثقفين فاا بالحالتين
انا رايي يعني
محلينا المشكله تجربتك الشخصيه
ما واجهتها
عندما اختلفت
بالتوجهات
بعد بعد يعني او خلال فتره 82
انا تركت 84
وبالتالي كان رايك في تمام مختلف بس ما له
علاقه
بانه يعني
منظمه العمل الشيوعي تنظيم يساري جذري
دخل
بالحركه الوطنيه اللبنانيه خلال الحرب
وبالتالي يعني جوابها على سؤالك المثقفين
خاطروا في لبنان عكس المستشفى
[موسيقى]
اه تخدم موقفا يعني واضحا مع الحركه
الفلسطينيه مع منظمه التحرير ضد العزاليا
اللبنانيه اشتبكتم في هذه الحرب كنتم جزء
منها وكان لنا راي اجتهاد نحن والفاق
بالحزب الشيوعي شوي مختلف لانه يعني
يصور للخارج وكانه في
انقسام فقط حول همم
يعني البلد انشق حول اما الاصلاح السياسي
وتجاوز النظام الطائف واما التمسك به بحجه
ان يعني الدستور لا يمس وهو مقدس وبالتالي
نحن كنا على راس 10 سنوات من النضالات
الشعبيه همم
والاجتماعيه تبدا من الطلاب ولا تنتهي
يعني
بالفلاح الشمال او ال
او او الجنوب وهي تطالب اولا يعني الغاء
النظام الطائي
بتجاوزه
يعني اشكال ماء من العداله الاجتماعيه ومن
التنميه فهذا برنامج اخر
العنوان الحرب
عنوان الحرب الاثنين يعني الرابط بينهن
واجب وهو انه من عاند الاصلاح خلال عشر
سنين اتكى على الجيش
وبدا ال ال
التسلح وهو حزب الكتائب ويعني احزاب الجبل
اللبنانيه والطرف الاخر يعني اتكا على
وجود المقاومه الفلسطينيه للضغط من اجل
الاصلاح يعني انا سميت
العمليه الاصلاح بواسطه السلاح طبعا
الحركه الوطنيه اللبنانيه كان كان يعني
برنامج الاساسي مزدوج حمايه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالحدود وبالنفس الوقت اه
الاصلاح البرنامج الاساسي كان اسمه اصلاح
المرحله همم برنامج المرحله الاصلاح
الديمقراطي وهو اقتصاد
بالمطالب شعبيه جامعه همم
وطنيه مدعومه و
مجموعه
[موسيقى]
المطاليق تتعلق بنظام الانتخابي جديد خارج
القيد الطائف حصر التمثيل الطائفي بمجلس
الشيوخ
وشي سميناه
قانون الاحوال
يلزمك بانك تتبع تشريعات مذهبك وفي 18
مزبديني فانا نحن نقول انه كان لازم يعطه
اللبنانيين الحق بنختار انه ما يتبع مذهبه
يطبع همم
قول انه اختياري لمعرفه حساسيه الموضوع
لمعرفه انه ترك فرصه للناس تمام خلي الناس
لبنانيه
للنظار الشيعي بشكل عام هو اللي حركه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اريد ان نلخص هذين
الامرين يعني بافكار اساسيه اليوم واحنا
على بعد 40 سنه او اكثر بعد من من تلك
الاحداث اولا انا يعني في شيء بالمناسبه
البرنامج الذي طرح برنامج يصلح ان يكون
البرنامج الوطني
بتاسيس مساهمه بتاسيس جبهه المقاومه
الوطنيه اللبنانيه
ولم اراجع يعني موضوع انه في مشكله اساسيه
هي ضروره الدفاع في لبنان عن همم
بوش اسرائيل ولم ولما يعني اغير من رايي
بانه لبنان على همم ضعفه لازم يكون محصل
بوجه اسرائيل هذا لبنا باقي عربيه ثاني
اما تجربه اليسار قلت لك نحنا دخلنا
يعني اول شيء بيقولوا لي انا يعني كيف
دخلت اسمه حرب يعني تبدا بمجموعه همم
معارك
ستنتهي
وتنزلق يعني اليسار لعب دوره باول سنتين
لا وجود لنا بعدين اليسار لعب دور اول
الجيش
نظام الطائف ويكون فيه يعني طاقم جديد
يعني ذو حساسيه اجتماعيه هذا قضي عليه همم
بناء على يعني تطورات اقليميه هي الاساس
يعني بالموضوع يعني الحركه الوطنيه
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه كانه سيطرين على
الاسم الاكبر من الاراضي اللبنانيه الذي
ترى هو تمام
سمي جبل لبنانيه العزاليه طلعوا طلعت
الهروب منزليه يعني اذا يعني اولا يعني
الاساسي كان هو مسيره كامب ديفيد
ومسيره كامب ديفيد يعني
هذا الطرف على اساس اذا طرف مئات فلسطيني
سوري تبدا
انه ما في يعني بطاريات صواريخ همم ما
بيشغل
السنتيات ودائما يعني سوريا النظام السوري
الحديث دائما لديه هذه الانضباطيه العاليه
الجاهزه اسرائيليه لا كانها ايه هو كان
وكان الغرض الاساسي الامساك بالمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهمم فشي العمليه
في في حركه النظام الشيوعي الثبات التي لم
تقدم لم تذكر لنا المراجعتك اين كانت
تحديدا في تجربه همم
كل كتاباته هي كنايه عن يعني هذا حظي كبير
في الحياه اني اختبرت تجارب من الثورات
العربيه بما فيها اذا فيك سميه الثوره
اللبنانيه هي شكلت ماده يعني همم
ملخصا يعني افكار الرئيسيه تعتقد انها
تشكل حاله نقديه لتجربه النظام الشيوعي
اولا ال- ال- الحركه الشيوعيه واليسريه
انا بحكي عن اثنين اليسار الجديد والحركه
الشيوعيه هم كانوا الجناح الي صارم حركه
التحرر العرب
وعندما انتصرت حركه التحرر العربي انشق
هذا جناح اللي ارتقي الى السلطه عن الجناح
اللي خارج السلطه وهي يعني بدايه تصفيات
لليسار يعني مصر
التصفيه الدمويه العراق ثم السودان
فبالتالي يعني الانقسام القومي في السلطه
مع ال- ال- الحركه الشيوعيه اولا كان اول
ضربه تتلقاها هذه الحركه اثنين
انا بعتقد هذا العالم كله الان يواجه
مرحله تاريخيه تمام مختلفين اسمه 1980
والعولمه
هذا تحدي على كل
الهيئه على كل حركه السياسيه
عند زوال الاتحاد السوفيتي الصغيره
اما التيار قومي متشددي واما التيار
لبيرالي شبه امريكاني
لما اظلم يعني
ببلادنا القهر بيجعل
خاصه لا يوجد
من التعبير
بانظمه ديمقراطيه في حزب لبراء الفيديو
اليسار الجديد
[موسيقى]
الاثر القليل لتركه الاتحاد السوفيتي على
فكره
على فكره اللي كان يعني معظمه
فكر
استراتيجيه الاتحاد السوفيتي يعني شيل
اسمه طريق الانتقال السلمي الى الاشتراكيه
يعني التدريب النظري بالاتحاد السوفيتي لم
تمنع لم تسمح
بمركسيه خلاقه يعني تنتج كثير من
من
المعارف حول السلطه والدولي
فهذا الجهاز الان ااه بحاجه الى اعاده نظر
سياده الفكري بيضاء المستجدات وبالتالي
هذا تحدي
ورفع التحدي موضوع فكره
على كاتب غزير الانتاج يبدو انك كتبت
متاخرا بعض الشيء بدات الكتابه
في ظل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قطعا كان الانشغالك في العمل الحزب
السياسي
لا ان الامر لم يتبلور بشكل كامل بسؤال
شرعي كتبت كثير
مقالات صحفيه
انما يعني
هل هل القرار الوعي اذا بدك لاخذت
بعد بعد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عم ب 82 وهو ال ااه
الكتابه الاهليه وهو الموضوع الان انواع
مختلفه عن الكتابه
[موسيقى]
الكتاب الكتاب عن
هذه التجارب ايه يعني تعتقد انه التاليف
جاء متاخرا بمعنى كتب
اجتياح بيروت اجتياح لبنان
الشيوعي بعدها بدات عمليه الكتابه وشخصيه
الكاتب وتظهر وتتبلور بشكلكتني انا قابلت
ابي سلايم وقابلت الى مبابي كان ايضا
اجتياح بيروت محطه مفصليه في تحولهم
الكبير
ما تلاها كان يعني
قرار اذا سببها بالعمل الحزب اذا اجده ان
ابقى في العمل الحزبي او ان اواصل دراسي
وان انقل هذه التجاري
مش بس التجارب يعني ان ان اعمل
من روحي هذه التجارب على يعني ايه انتاج
معارف
من يعني تتغذى من هذه التجارب بس مش
مختصره بها المذكرات اولا بدات بالمذكرات
وبدات يعني قرار هو انه ما بيكفي التعبير
السياسي عن صراعات سياسيه واجتماعيه ممكن
البحث عنه تعبير عنه اشكال مختلفه
فاصدرت كتاب اسمه
وهو قراءه في لوحه بيكاسو من وحي عيون
شهدت حرب اهليه يعني لو واحد بكسر الحرب
الاهليه الاسبانيه
هذا يعني عام 87
تمام
[موسيقى]
هذا الجناح من اليسار الجديد براي السنفذ
دوره خاصه انه اختلط الى حد كبير
بالحركه الوطنيه
عندما امين العام نقل وصار الامين العام
تنفيذي حاولوا بجبه قوي كبير وبالتالي
التنظيم اليسار اللي يعني سهم بتاسيسه همم
فقد هويته الاساسيه اول سبب لم نؤسس يعني
علاقات ديموقراطيه لاسباب مختلفه بما في
ذلك يعني انه كنا نفرط التنظيم بكل مناسبه
يعني نفرض تنظيم بالحركه الاجتماعيه ثم
يعني تحويل تنظيم الى تنظيم مقاوم
عسكري التنظيم تفرض منطقه اخر تمام على
التنظيم يغلب في الاوامر
والتالي يعني لم تكن تجري بناجحه في يعني
تنظيم يساري وديموقراطي
علما انه يعني هذا القرار اعطيته الطابع
الفرد لانه ما كان رايي انه
يجب قيام انشقاقات
وتحملت يعني ثمن اني خرج منفرده يعني انت
اخرجت هناك قصه فردي كمساله فرديه
يعني
التنظيم المعنى ضمره كثيره
هو نفسه بسبب
هذا العالم الجديد اللي ما استمر اسمه
اليسار الجديد عالميا وعربيه
لما حدث لاحقا للاتحاد السوفيتي نهار بعد
ذلك بسنوات يعني الدوله الكبرى الراعيه
على الاقل لهذا العناوين علما بانه نحن
طرف لم يكن لنا يعني كنا طرف مستقلا
الاتحاد السوفيتي انا كاتب مقالات نقديه
عن الاتحاد السوفيتي في مجالتنا
بحياتي الاتحاد السوفيتي ولم ادعى ولم
يضحك دعاني
دعمك وتمويل المساعده طلابيه
هل معنا يعني
انهيار قسم الظاهر يعني الاحزاب شويه
واليسار الجديد بدون
ليس سببا فرديه ايه بس التعبير الفردي
حق فيه في حين انه في رثاء
ثم تحول التنظيم الى شيء اخر يعني منظمه
العمل الشيوعي الان غيروا له اسمه يعني
صار تنظيم اذا بدك ديمقراطي همم علماني
هو انا مش هذا همي بمعنى ما انه
الديمقراطيه العلمانيه بلا بلا يعني
[موسيقى]
زنبرك بلا عنصر
يعني فكري بيجمعهم
مكان بعيد
الوله بالعلمانيه
عقيده العلمانيه اجراء يعني له علاقه
الدوله
[موسيقى]